S
BELIEVE BUT A SMALL MINORITY OF
REPUBLICAN OFFICEHOLDERS SAY OUT
LOUD BECAUSE IT'S TOO SCARY.
IT TELLS YOU SO MUCH.
TULSI GABBARD JOINS US TONIGHT
WE ARE HAPPY SHE IS WITH US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THAT WAS QUITE A STATEMENT.
I'M LISTENING TO THIS AND
THINKING WE HAVE REPUBLICANS ON
THE SHOW FROM TIME TO TIME AND
THEY DON'T PUT IT AS CLEARLY AND
BRAVELY AS YOU DO.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THIS PARTY A LONG
TIME?
YOU WERE ITS FUTURE.
HE LEFT.
IT'S GOT TO BE KIND OF A FRAUD
MOMENT.
>> TUCKER, AS YOU KNOW, I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN AN INDEPENDENT
MINDED PERSON.
DEMOCRAT YES BUT INDEPENDENT
DEMOCRAT.
MY LOYALTIES ARE VERY CLEAR.
I LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND I TOOK AN
OATH AS A SERVICE MEMBER, AS A
SOLDIER, AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TO SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S AN OATH I TAKE EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS PARTY,
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
CONTROLLED BY FANATICAL
IDEOLOGUES WHO HATE FREEDOM.
THEY DESPISE THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY ACTIVELY FIND WAYS TO
UNDERMINE OUR GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS
ENSHRINED IN THE CONSTITUTION
LIKE FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING AND I SAY
SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T LIKE,
INSTEAD OF SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT,
AGREE TO DISAGREE, LIVE AND LET
LIVE, THE TRADITIONAL LIBERALIST
KIND OF WAY, NO.
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THEY WILL DO ALL THEY CAN TO
DESTROY YOU, SILENCE YOU, SMEAR
WITH YOU, WORK WITH BIG TECH,
CORPORATE MEDIA TO ACTIVELY
DESTROY ANYONE WHO DARES EVEN
QUESTION THEIR AGENDA.
THEY ARE AGAINST FREEDOM OF
RELIGION.
THEY ARE HOSTILE TOWARDS PEOPLE
OF FAITH, PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEIR
OWN SPIRITUAL PRACTICE,
ESPECIALLY CHRISTIANS FINDING
WAYS TO BE VINDICTIVE, TO
DISCRIMINATE, TO PUNISH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN TO EXERCISE THAT
FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON BUT THE
FOUNDATION OF FREEDOM IS REALLY
WHAT WAS AT THE HEART OF MY
MAKING THIS DECISION THAT I
CANNOT BE A MEMBER OF THE PARTY
THAT IS AGAINST FREEDOM AND
ACTIVELY TRYING TO UNDERMINE IT.
>> Tucker: INSPIRING TO HEAR
THAT BUT ALSO DISAPPOINTING.
IF YOU LIKE PRINTING OUT YOUR
WORDS AND ASKING EVERY
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE COMES ON
THE SHOW TO READ THEM IF YOU CAN
READ THEM I'M NOT VOTING FOR
YOU.
WHY IS IT SO HARD TO SAY OUT
LOUD FIRST OF ALL THE PEOPLE
ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT RACISM ARE
COMMITTING IT.
WHY IS THAT SO HARD FOR PEOPLE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
IT'S SO OBVIOUS.
>> IT SPEAKS TO THE WHOLE
ENVIRONMENT OF FEAR THAT THOSE
IN POWER, THE ELITISTS AND POWER
HAVE FOMENTED TO WHERE PEOPLE
ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT LOSE YOUR JOB.
YOU MIGHT BE CANCELED.
YOU MIGHT BE TRASHED.
GOD FORBID IN WASHINGTON YOU
MIGHT NOT BE INVITED TO THE COOL
KIDS PARTIES.
YOU MIGHT NOT BE AS POPULAR.
THIS IS REALLY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO.
RATHER THAN TAKING A STAND FOR
PEACE, PROSPERITY, SECURITY AND
FREEDOM OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WE HAVE TOO MANY PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON WHO ARE WARMONGERS
SUBSERVIENT TO THE
MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX AND
CONTINUING TO PUT THEIR OWN
SELFISH INTERESTS, THE INTERESTS
OF THEIR DONORS FIRST WITH NO
MIND FOR THE COST AND
CONSEQUENCE THAT THEIR DECISIONS
HAVE ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND LEADERS IN
CONGRESS WHOSE DECISIONS ARE
ACTIVELY PUSHING US TO THE BRINK
OF A NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST OF WHICH
THEY MAY HAVE THEIR BUNKERS
WHERE THEY WILL BE SAFE THAT WE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL HAVE NO
SHELTER, NO PLACE TO GO, NO
PLACE TO HIDE.
FACE THE CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD
DESTROY ALL OF HUMANITY IN THE
WORLD AS WE KNOW IT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE THE FIRST
PERSON I HEARD SAY THAT IN
FEBRUARY WHEN THIS ALL STARTED.
>> IT'S WHY I RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: IT TURNS OUT YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SINCE YOU DID SERVE HERSCHEL
MANY YEARS IN THE HAS ANYONE
CALLED YOU, FORMER COLLEAGUES,
DEMOCRATS TO SAY ANYTHING TO
YOU?
>> ONE GOT IN TOUCH WITH ME AND
SENT ME A TEXT MESSAGE WITH
THREE THUMBS UP.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW THAT IS.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE INFLUENCING
PEOPLE.
TULSI GABBARD, I'M NOT GOING TO
ASK YOU WHAT YOU'R